well I never really thought of the media
was that some kind of boogie man that
something has to change I mean the media
now is so diverse and so complex there's
so much of it you know you can find
problems with anything I suppose but the
fact of the matter is a lot of media
today isn't targeted to me a reason
target with any person in particular
they look for certain market segments
and they go for them and they really
don't care anything about anybody else
or what anybody else thinks and you know
professionally I was part of that
process for a long time but I do believe
today if you're an active involved
educated thoughtful person you can find
a mix of media that appeals to you
satisfies you more readily and better
than any point in time in history so you
can say oh my god the media they're so
exploitative they lean towards a
sensational thing or they don't have
enough international news coverage but
you know it's your decision what you
want to watch and there's just so many
other options I really have a hard time
feeling sorry for anybody who has that
point of view
you